hi my name is Eric Schmidt I'm a
developer advocate in the Google cloud
platform team focused on data processing
and analysis in this video I'm going to
review core architectural concepts for
performing streaming data processing and
then I will use the Google cloud
platform specifically three managed
services cloud pub/sub cloud dataflow
and bigquery to implement several near
real-time streaming data processing
patterns this content is targeted at
programmers and developers and
architects interested in building
cloud-based streaming processing systems
if you already have deep knowledge
around modern streaming engines like
Apache spark apache storm or apache
flink some of this content may be
redundant however if you're new to the
cloud or have not looked at manage
services on the Google cloud platform
this video should prove useful to you
this video has three main sections
well first introduce a sample scenario
to help contextualize the concepts and
business challenges related to streaming
data processing then I'll review a
collection of architectural principles
and demonstrate how to use manage
services on the Google cloud platform to
perform streaming processing and
analysis after watching this video you
should have a clear understanding on how
to implement streaming data processing
workflows with managed services on the
Google cloud platform this past spring I
was fortunate to work with Spotify as
engineering team on their streaming data
processing architecture while they were
migrating to the Google cloud platform
now in my spare time I'm also a DJ at
kxp 90.3 here in Seattle and as such I'm
deeply passionate about music the sample
for this work was inspired by my work at
kxp
a my work with Spotify I encourage you
to go read Spotify three-part blog post
on their overall data processing
architecture you can find the series on
the Spotify labs blog or simply Google
modify event delivery architecture my
sample scenario was called testify and
is based on a very simplified
architecture and the resulting analysis
is quite narrow mainly not to overshadow
the main theme of this video which is
about understanding extrema processing
the sample is based on a fabricated
event log data from a mobile music
application to which I apply several
fabricated questions and these questions
were inspired by some innovative work
that Spotify is doing around bigquery
now to be clear this sample is about
processing event data not about
streaming music the logical model is as
follows I have a fake mobile device and
it emits events of different meaning and
of different schema these events are
pushed to Ed servers hosting application
services and these services emit local
event logs these logs are then tailed in
real time and ingest it into a queue and
from there I will apply some ETL
processing and run some transforms to
move that data into a durable store for
further interactive analysis
dashboarding and batch reporting the
architectural concepts in this video can
be applied to nearly any business
challenge across any vertical from fraud
detection to advertising campaign
analysis to inventory stock out alerting
to real-time leaderboards in the same
architectural concepts apply regardless
of vertical or workload
I picked the music event processing
sample because it's fun and well at
least for me is something that I really
love now I'd like to review a collection
of terms and tenets related to data
processing we will revisit the testify
sample but in the meantime please keep
some of the top level flow in mind now
throughout this video I will
deliberately coalesce the concepts and
physical manifestations of data
processing and data analysis into the
phrase data processing to simplify the
messaging
however they are different data
processing is primarily about movement
and transformation aka ETL for example
extracting log files and transforming
them filtering them and then loading
them to
another location orderable store data
analysis is primary about applying
computation or aggregations things like
count sum etc over group collections for
example performing statistical analysis
over all data elements or sampled
analysis for example counting the number
of users that listen to a particular
song by hour or by minute now in the
context of streaming analysis it's also
common to join streams with other
streams and to join streams with at rest
or batch data I make this distinction up
front as the architectural implications
for processing and analysis are quite
different however in practice they're
commonly blended into the same logical
model and in some cases the same
physical system now no matter what
business vertical you operate in finance
healthcare manufacturing and casual
gaming or the discipline in which you
work accounting marketing sales customer
service the number one blocker for
growth is a concept I like to call time
to answer specifically how fast can you
get the answer to a question pertinent
to your business at that time in almost
all cases you're ultimately dependent
upon data processing and analysis
systems to answer these questions let's
say you're let's say you're an
advertising analyst for a retail company
the time to answer our key question like
what is the conversion rate on my
current marketing campaign could mean
the difference between driving a demand
ad inventory to the right customers or
possibly wasting dollars on already
stocked out products if you're in the
manufacturing space focused on
production line efficiency knowing the
answer to a question like what is the
current distribution of to be process
orders and how do those orders align to
my existing machine setup this could be
the difference between positive and
negative margins on your next production
run or a question like if you're a
casual game developer what percentage of
users recently abandoned my game as a
result of introducing new game logic
the time to answer here could have
massive impact on your daily active
users or maybe you become the focus of
the next episode of Silicon Valley now
the theme across these questions is
speed I've never met a business or
technical decision maker that said I'd
really like to have questions to my
answers with more delay the converse is
true it's the true state of business
today now more than ever those who can
answer questions faster are more likely
to succeed and grow the challenge is
that growth creates more data and in
turn creates more questions that's more
pressure on processing and analysis
systems and when implemented incorrectly
these underlying systems increase the
time to answer time to answer matters
now for decades businesses have been
using various techniques for data
processing batch being one of the most
common patterns to answer questions like
the ones I've previously raised a while
effective bat processing on fixed
capacity non-managed environments
present risks related to cost control
increased time to answer and answer
accuracy or rather answer in accuracy
let's look at a simple example here we
have a fixed data set which we process
via a batch job on a fixed cluster of
resources when these resources are ready
and this job scheduled time is hit to
start the job starts the job and the
resources are effectively blocked until
the job is completed after the job is
completed results are emitted there is
an effective clock time for this job
this is in essence the time to answer
for example this job took 30 clock
minutes to run and consumed a total of
200 minutes of resource time now we're
going to extend the example let's add a
new job in this case the new job will be
blocked when the existing job is running
the typical response here is to add more
resources CPU memory disk and network
capacity and deploy the job to these new
specific resources now one of the
challenge is that you end up potentially
wasting resources notice
that the previous job is not complete
and the initial resources are now idle
now that the second job is complete our
entire collection of resources is idle
if you have experience with the dupe
clusters you might be thinking well this
is what the resource manager and yarn
are for and yes they can be highly
effective at optimizing resources based
on scheduling semantics however the
issue here is that if there are no jobs
to be scheduled the resources will
remain idle and in some cases they just
may be better to be torn down the other
challenges is that if you need to
increase capacity on the cluster in an
unmanaged environment you're going to
have to physically deploy and manage the
life cycle of those resources let's take
a look at the first job scenario again
now at the time that the job was
scheduled the input data is effectively
locked in relational database terms you
could think about this as an effective
page lock over the entire data set
however in this case some data arrives
late after the job has started and it
was really supposed to be part of the
original input set now the job finishes
output is created but the output is now
only partially correct or possibly
completely inaccurate depending on the
impact of the late data there are many
techniques to deal with this problem now
if the job computation here is
associative one could rerun the job
against the new data and add the results
to the original job output or one could
delete the original results and rerun
the entire job again
each approach has its own challenges and
risks well to be clear I'm not saying
that all batch processing is bad or that
all unmanaged data processing is bad I
simply want to point out that there are
inherent challenges for each approach
and depending on your use cases data
volumes and analysis requirements and
resource budget you may encounter these
issues the next several concepts I'm
going to talk about are grafted from two
blog posts recently written by an
amazing software engineer and also the
technical lead for the mill wheel team
here at Google his name is Tyler Aikido
I encourage you to go read them
simply google streaming 101 and they
show up at the top of the stack because
they're highly relevant and they're
highly popular in the previous unmanage
back section I talked about
late-arriving data and its impact on the
output of the batch job now as I start
to talk about streaming processing I
want to establish a distinction between
the data specifically it's boundedness
and the processing approach this concept
is super helpful in understanding the
valuable heat behaviors of a streaming
system and how they might be able to be
applied to your processing problems so
let's talk about boundedness bounded
data is finite it's at rest it does not
change for example you may have 10
terabytes of historical weblog data and
specifically in files an avro format or
JSON sitting at rest in a blob store
unbounded data is infinite it's
constantly changing it's driven by
frequency it's driven by changes in size
and potentially in schema and the time
associated with the data and the stream
may be relevant to the event time or to
its processing time for example you may
be listening to a TCP socket and reading
all the weblog data coming from all of
your servers processing specifically in
this case bounded processing think of
this as classic batch processing
specifically a processing engine applied
to bounded data and the same for
unbounded this is a specific mode of
processing applied to an unbounded
source it's important to understand
these definitions as their underlying
implementations creates specific
architectural boundaries in my previous
batch example the data was in fact
unbounded however the system was
treating it as bounded data this is a
very common pattern where one would run
periodic batch jobs over unbounded data
say contained in a relational database
like sequel server or a no sequel store
like [ __ ] it's a very valid approach
but it can lead to correctness issues
or make a pattern say like session
analysis very challenging in addition to
boundedness the time domain associated
with data can have a major impact on how
data is processed and the correctness of
the processing output event time is an
explicit time associated with a data
element or events tied to the clock time
of when and where the event occurred in
most cases the time is highly
distributed and potentially volatile
processing time is the time associated
with the processing engine in some cases
it might be the time the engine ingested
the data and others it might be the time
associated with the step or stage being
executed within the engine in most cases
this time is centralized or synchronized
with a common time service let's use an
example I just played Justin Bieber on
my testify application at 12:14 GMT on
July 25th 2016 that was the event time
however this event was processed three
minutes later by my streaming processing
engine now the distinction between event
time and processing time here is
important because it will ultimately
impact the correctness of my processing
output for example if I was trying to
count plays by minute my results would
be skewed by three minutes if I was
using processing time now what I really
wanted to know is I want to do kind of
plays by minute where time is relative
to the actual play time not processing
time now the minimum Delta between event
time and processing time is relative to
the speed of light plus some additional
latency which we'll talk about next the
regardless of batch or streaming modes
if you are dealing with unbounded data
and you want to process data based on
event time you need to understand your
latency exposure and then employ
techniques to deal with late arriving
data in a perfect world latency would be
zero well it would at least be a bounded
by the speed of light or it'd be nice if
you could understand and have some type
of fixed overall system latency
but we don't live in a perfect world in
my testify example there are three areas
that could create latency on the
transmission side from my phone to the
cloud it could be something as simple as
Network unavailability or it could be
something very downstream like a slow
disk that is backing a queue and those
reads are now reduced on the throughput
side which would create latency in
almost all cases you don't have control
over these potential issues but the best
thing you can do is plan for what level
of latency you can expect and that
you're willing to tolerate and have a
plan with how you deal with later
arriving data I'll talk more about how
you deal with late arriving data in the
next section now that we understand
event versus processing time and the
impact of latency we need an additional
primitive to rationalize time into
manageable groups having the ability to
window data into finite chunks enables
computation that would otherwise be
impossible for example without windowing
it'd be very difficult to perform even a
simple aggregation like count or sum
over unbounded data in essence you need
a mechanism to group all events into a
window in order to apply an aggregation
to a window that has some level of data
completeness in classic MapReduce you'd
create keys that were tied to start and
ends of windows and other systems say
like apache storm you could set the
timestamp for a tuple and then that
timestamp is propagated into a window
now not all processing systems support
our window types I'll talk a little bit
later about specific windowing support
in different processing engines before I
stop talking about time I need to cover
another important concept that is
tightly bound that is tightly bound to
latency which is the concept of a
watermark here you can see event time on
the x-axis and processing time on the
y-axis
in a perfect zero latency world we could
use in a deal watermark that moves
linearly tied to clock time but the
world is not fair and latency is
everywhere thus if we're going to
perform processing based on event time
we need a heuristic driven watermark now
this watermark is an estimate based on
various techniques for example a simple
distribution sampler or something more
sophisticated like looking at the oldest
unprocessed message in an upstream queue
now if the heuristic is too slow results
are delayed if the heuristic is too fast
results may be marked late now in this
example I'm doing some fixed window
analysis notice that in the event time
window of 12:01 to 1202 there is an
event of value 9 but it's been marked as
red because it was processed way past
the watermark it was marked late the
question is what do you do with late
data I'm gonna talk a little bit more
later about how to deal with late data
as well as how to trigger speculative
results within a window we can now tie
all these concepts together and end on a
crisp definition of streaming streaming
is an execution engine system service
runner capable of processing unbounded
data and when designed correctly a
streaming processing engine can provide
low latency speculative or partial
results the ability to flexibly reason
about time provide controls for
correctness and ultimately the power to
perform complex analysis now that I have
the basic terms and tenets laid out for
streaming processing I'm going to use
several managed services on the Google
cloud platform to build a streaming data
processing application specifically I'm
going to use cloud pub/sub for ingestion
cloud dataflow for processing and
imperative analysis and bigquery for
durable storage and interactive analysis
cloud pub/sub is a managed service for
streaming data on the Google cloud
platform cloud pub/sub Mable's durable
asynchronous messaging
patients including patterns for
one-to-one one-to-many and many-to-many
cloud pub/sub is globally available with
large mesh it size support up to 10
megabytes per put and cloud pub/sub
provides at least once delivery with low
latency and on-demand scalability to 1
million messages per second and beyond
now pub/sub is technically a streaming
engine as it can process unbounded data
however it does not provide mechanisms
for reasoning about time or the ability
to express computation over the stream
we will use other services to perform
processing and analysis as you can see
pub/sub is a hub to enable streams to
flow in and out of GCP services moreover
it can be connected to any service on
the cloud or on-premise via HTTP or
directly over sockets via G RPC pub/sub
uses a simple topic subscription model
to enable fan-in and fan-out messaging
topologies and my testify example I may
route all events to a single topic or I
could split event types across topics
and then multiplex them to multiple
subscribers here is a zoomed view of my
testified demo application I'm going to
show you how to set up a cloud pub/sub
topic to ingest an unbounded stream
which will then be processed by cloud
dataflow in this case I'll be using one
topic to ingest the stream of events
being generated by a data fabricator
which mimics log creation there are
several ways to interact with cloud
pub/sub you can use the REST API one of
the Google cloud client language
libraries or for basic management
operations you can use the Google Cloud
console you can see that I have two
existing topics in my Google Cloud
console I'll create a new topic called
testified demo
now once I hit create this topic is
globally available to receive messages
at a default rate up to 100 megabytes
per second with a maximum message size
of 10 megabytes if you need additional
quota please follow the instructions in
the quota section of the cloud pub/sub
documentation now you'll notice that
there's no force to sharding or
bucketing when you set up your topic
simply give it a name call create and
then start publishing data now let's
look at something a little bit more
interesting I previously created a topic
called testify events this is receiving
my fabricated event data this topic has
two active subscriptions these were
created by my cloud dataflow job reading
the event stream now let's look at this
topic in my management console called
stock driver stack driver is a real-time
monitoring logging and diagnostic
service for Google cloud AWS and open
source packages here I created a
dashboard for my pub/sub resources
showing four graphs my publish rate my
pull rate the number of undelivered
messages and the oldest unacknowledged
message time you can create your own
graphs based on event rate event size
errors and many other dimensions I built
these graphs in order to monitor the
overall lag in my event processing
system now I'm publishing right now at
approximately a hundred and one to a
hundred thousand events per second and
I'm reading or pulling them at roughly
the same rates and my undelivered
message count is rain around between 150
and 200 thousand messages cloud pub/sub
has a built-in 7-day retention policy
for undelivered messages if I were to
say shut down my downstream reader in
this case cloud dataflow all the
messages would be durably stored for
seven days now one last highlight that
is helpful for cloud pub/sub workflow as
many other workflows like complete
storage etc
is the ability to create custom alerting
policies which can monitor specific
metrics and thresholds and then send you
notifications here I had created a
policy to check a particular metric in
this case I wanted to look at messages
published for my testify events topic if
it was above a threshold of 50,000
events per second for greater than one
minute and in this case it would alert
the dashboard as well as send me an
email now that you understand the basics
of cloud pub/sub and we've set up a
topic and showed you some management
techniques and we have a live topic and
subscription running let's look at how
cloud dataflow is processing the stream
Google Cloud dataflow is a managed data
processing service and an open source
programming model that unifies batch and
streaming processing into one model the
cloud dataflow service provides
on-demand resource deployment and
management on a per job basis this means
you can scale your data processing
without resource contention and limits
found in fixed clusters the service
automatically scales resources up and
down for both batch and streaming jobs
freeing you from under or over
provisioning resources and enabling you
to optimize your time to answer the
cloud dataflow programming model was the
basis for the now open source Apache
Software Foundation incubator project
called Apache beam a functionally cloud
dataflow unifies batch and streaming
into one model it enables processing in
processing time space as well as event
time space it provides a windowing
primitives with support for fixed
sliding and session windows that support
advanced triggering mechanisms for
speculative window emission and to deal
with late arriving data the cloud
dataflow managed service is geared at
driving a no ops or no operations
deployment and management model instead
of you spending time downloading
packages
spinning up compute resources tuning
cluster configuration and dealing with
control plane issues
you simply code your pipeline and submit
your pipeline as a job to the service
and it handles the rest you're only
charged for the time that your job
executes on the service since resources
are deployed and man is completely on
demand you can reduce the capital cost
of deploying and managing long-running
fix capacity clusters the service can
seamlessly transition between batch and
streaming processing providing a single
service to handle bounded and unbounded
data processing
now with forthcoming Apache beam support
you will be able to migrate your data
flow jobs across a patchy SPARC Apache
flink and other runners here is a
logical view of a simple cloud dataflow
pipeline for my testify workflow you
submit the pipeline as a job and the
service will then deploy the worker
resources and schedule the work in this
case I start with a bounded source
I read the log data apply some simple
transformations and then write it to
various charts now let's migrate this to
an unbounded source and turn this into a
streaming process nothing changes with
the pipeline other than changing the
source finally let's add some windowing
and add a simple aggregator in this case
account I could continue to add more and
more branches to the pipeline I could
split the graph I could apply varying
windows and even apply more
sophisticated aggregations this is a
view of my running cloud dataflow
streaming job which is processing the
events published into my pub/sub topic
and flowing to related subscriptions it
has been running for a little over two
hours and 40 minutes and it has
processed around nine hundred and
seventy-one million events the graph
starts by reading event data from
pub/sub this event data is text CSV
format it you could also process JSON
Avro XML or create your own custom
format now of important notes I'm use
event time as my time domain not
processing time to do this I tell
dataflow to look for a specific label on
each pub/sub message called timestamp
from their data flow handles the
calculation of the data watermark which
as the watermark advances any window
ending before or at that time will be
closed I'm using event time here in
order to provide a higher level of
accuracy format aggregations if I were
to use processing time I never could be
guaranteed to have all the data relevant
to a specific event time window after
reading the raw stream data data is sent
to parse transform this transform has
two steps parse and deserialize
deserialized maps the parse csv data
into an object called event from here
the job has three main goals goal number
one is focused on archiving and is
mainly a load function in terms of a
typical ETL job specifically i want to
do some basic formatting on every event
and write each event to a durable store
for additional processing or analysis in
this case my durable store is bigquery
note this data is assigned to the jobs
global window and does not wait for any
specific window to close in essence it
is processed as fast as possible in this
case it's written to bigquery via its
streaming API the lean seat for this
data is a function of transmit time plus
pub/sub time plus data flow time plus
availability time in the downstream
store now since I'm not using windowing
this latency calculation may not be very
helpful if you're trying to determine
data completeness more specifically if
you're trying to perform analysis over
the raw events in this case in bigquery
your analysis may be partially
inaccurate if you are addressing event x
within the latency window there are
specific techniques to deal with late
arriving data as well as omitting early
results which I will address next goal
number two is to calculate the total
number of plays per track per ten-minute
fix
window and I want to update the output
every 15 seconds view this output like a
meter as time progresses the metrics
should increase as long as events arrive
for that particular track II since I
have a fixed window I can enforce the
duration for how long I want to tolerate
late data in this case since I'm doing
some dashboarding my threshold is small
only 15 seconds any late data arriving
outside of the 10-minute window plus 15
seconds will be ignored
now each key specifically a track ID
will have up to 40 updates updating 15
seconds processing time over a 10-minute
window in the testify use case there are
hundreds of thousands of tracks to deal
with this volume of highly mutating data
I am using cloud BigTable as the durable
storm the latency for this metric will
be transmitted time plus pub/sub time
plus 15 seconds plus any additional lag
in closing the window plus BigTable
right time now writes the BigTable
happened in milliseconds which greatly
reduces the overall latency from the
metric value goal number three is more
of a data warehousing pattern its
purpose is to drive a roll-up
aggregation I want to calculate the
total number of plays per track per
15-minute window and in this case I also
want to address any late arriving data
up to five minutes after the window
closes the latency here is transmitted
time plus pub/sub time plus 15 minutes
plus any additional lag and closing the
window plus right time now there's also
the possibility that data could arrive
late up to five minutes after the window
closes and since I'm using discarding
windows the new window will only contain
the late arriving data for downstream
consumers they can now be guaranteed
with high confidence that this
aggregation is a complete view of the
event stream for that time period and if
they see you later arriving data they
can choose how to handle it
now that you have a better idea of the
processing goals for this pipeline and
the power of data flows streaming
processing model look at what and how
you can perform additional analysis over
the stream and its aggregations using
bigquery and BigTable bigquery is a
fully managed data warehouse that
provides fast scalable interactive
analysis through familiar sequel syntax
queries can address a few bytes up to
petabytes and scale and also supports
real-time ingestion of data streams
bigquery can jest up to a hundred
thousand rows per second per table and
you can get additional throughput with
simple table starting this data is
available in seconds meaning a query
that is addressing at rest data can also
address data that was recently ingested
into an unbounded table the sources from
this data can come from places like
pub/sub data flow now bigquery is
technically a streaming engine since it
can deal with unbounded data however it
does not have the ability to rationalize
time space specifically it does not
understand late arriving data and does
not provide a triggering mechanism to
handle late data this is the role of an
upstream streaming engine like cloud
dataflow now if you have a steady handle
on end-to-end system latency directly
bypassing computation and data flow may
be a valid option at the same time if
you're using data flow to stream data
into bigquery it also makes a lot of
sense to potentially pre aggregate data
for example performing group buys and
simple aggregations that can then be
used for common queries as you will see
in my demo using bigquery is super
simple you don't have to worry about
indexing or restarting or storage
resizing or adding a server capacity you
simply load or stream your data into
bigquery and then execute a query this
is the power of managed services on the
Google cloud platform
this is the bigquery console in my
Google cloud project I have an existing
data set for my streaming workflow
called testify this data set contains
raw events streaming from my data flow
pipeline as well as other data like
track count by window and related data
like artist releases and labels let's
take a look at the event table the event
table schema is fairly straightforward
it has columns like event ID event time
user ID track ID and create time the
table itself is just a little over four
and a half terabytes in size now with
this raw event data I can create some
very big and interesting queries
especially if I join that raw event data
to other data here I want to calculate
the top artists by stream count to do
that I need to join my raw events to
track information and track information
to release credit in order to resolve
the artist name and then I'll do a group
by in order to get the track count now
it should take between 20 and 30 seconds
for this query to run there you go 26
and then a half seconds processing just
under half a terabyte of data and sadly
justin bieber is the top artist by total
streams now the power here is that I
didn't have to worry about charting or
indexes simply wrote my query and
executed it and having access to my
real-time information could be very
valuable depending on my data
completeness needs now let's take a look
at the output from the roll-up
aggregation driven by my dataflow job if
we recall this was account of tracks by
track ID by a 15-minute window and that
transform also handled late-arriving
data so I'm gonna go back and grab the
ID track ID from Justin Bieber and add
that as part of my where clause and run
this query so I'm going to filter on
Justin Bieber to see what his track
counts look like over time now since
this is a rollup query
ran much faster around 1.7 seconds and
you can see that the track count metric
is calculated by window that 15-minute
window and if data arrive late the
window
specifically the timing would have been
marked as late you can also see that the
latency between the end of the window
and the right time is roughly around 30
seconds so the total latency would be
the 15 minutes of the window plus the
latency of the right time or around 15
minutes and 30 seconds this is highly
accurate analysis against the real-time
stream now this is great but let's
explore even lower latency output from
our dashboarding transform the output
from that transform is written to cloud
BigTable cloud BigTable is Google's no
sequel big database service it's managed
and is designed to handle massive loads
with a consistent low latency in high
throughput it's an excellent solution
for highly mutating data over large key
ranges here's my current testify cluster
and as configured can handle reads and
writes at 30,000 QPS with a consistent
latency of 6 milliseconds now the
dashboarding transform from a dataflow
pipeline emits accumulating updates
every 15 seconds for a given track and
window key let's go back to the data
flow console and look at the current
data watermark for my cloud BigTable io
step so right now the data watermark is
at 21
41 I'm basically in the 40th minute
segments in the 2100 hour using my HBase
clients I'm going to call a get on
tracks tied to the tracked key for
Justin Bieber and I'm gonna look at the
fourth hour and 40th minutes when
and there's the value right now
he said twenty five thousand one hundred
and forty-seven streams in that window
now depending where I'm at in that 15
second cycle we should see that increase
probably caught it right on the end
there there you go so now it's at twenty
seven thousand three hundred and two and
this will continue to accumulate all the
way up to the four hour and fifty minute
window and then will cycle a new key and
the accumulator will start over so this
is fantastic I have thousands and
thousands of keys and I can continue to
mutate them the values over these
windows now the access time here is a
bit inflated so it's roughly about point
three eight seconds mainly because I'm
querying from my laptop into the cloud
if I was doing this on the cloud I'd be
seeing response times and 610
you know ish millisecond range the point
here is that this track count is dead
accurate within 15 seconds of the live
stream now let's pull this all together
I've built a dashboard in data studio
360 Google data studio 360 turns your
data into beautiful informative reports
that are easy to read and easy to share
it seamlessly integrates with bigquery
cloud sequel my sequel Google Analytics
Adwords and many other data sources I
chose it because it's easy to use but
you could easily apply these same
processing techniques to drive homegrown
reports or integrate the data into maybe
some existing tableau deployments once
you have your windowing and correctness
techniques doubt in the possibilities
are endless for highly accurate low
latency streaming data processing and
analysis now as I start to wrap up I
want to leave you with some general
guidance to start with ingest everything
and to be query now there are some
exceptions if you have very
fast-changing data cloud BigTable may be
a better fit for you
call BigTable is our managed H based
implementation it's good say if you're
building a real-time leaderboard and you
need to constantly update the same key
space BigTable is a much better fit
another thing to consider is decide if
you really need to do event time
processing and what cases do you need to
cover that require event time processing
event time processing is more resource
intensive to use so use it wisely I
strongly suggest that you use google
cloud dataflow to produce aggregations
that are going to be commonly used for
queries in another system say like
bigquery this will ultimately reduce the
time and resource costs related to those
queries here are some general guidance
for data flow as you get started now the
first one challenges everything that
I've said about streaming keep in mind
that streaming isn't a solution to all
problems for example a performing a bulk
database snapshot migration is much
better suited for a batch job and
specifically you could run that batch
job with cloud dataflow now the main
decision point about using batch or
streaming will be around the boundless
and your ability to deal with latency
and data correctness in either case of
batch or streaming utilize auto scaling
to remove the guesswork from resource
capacity planning if you are going to
use Windows specifically session windows
use them carefully they are very
powerful but they're also very resource
intensive a lot of cases you may be able
to use fixed windows over session
windows this next one may be obvious but
the guidance is to prune output from
your transforms inside of your pipeline
as much as possible this helps reduce
network transmission and serialization
overhead if you are using data flow in
streaming mode with pub/sub I encourage
you to use additional subscriptions in
order to do backfill or emergency replay
and finally I encourage you to use
custom transforms as much as possible
this will help with composer
as you build more and new pipelines for
bigquery out of the following guidance I
already said this but I'll say it again
ingest everything and to be query it's
cost-effective especially when
addressing historical data at a penny
per gig it is an excellent alternative
to standard blob storage plus you have
access to it via a query or via cloud
dataflow next guidance is select only
the columns that you need again sounds
obvious but I've seen query after query
that wastefully addresses data that is
never used
next consider restricting access to raw
event tables especially if you're
following this guidance around streaming
and streaming everything into bigquery
and you restrict access to a few folks
whose job it is to write queries to
answer business questions now unfettered
access to all data is great but it comes
with some risks both security concerns
as well as cost control fortunately
bigquery has a very flexible model to
control table access and finally if you
need more processing power simply
request more slots we're here to serve
streaming data processing when
implemented correctly can reduce the
time to answer and increase accuracy of
analysis event time processing is a
critical architectural need when
attempting to rationalize data
completeness now some streaming engines
are more robust than others and this is
a good thing it all comes down to the
ability to couple these systems together
and make sure that they work better
together managed services remove the
element of human interaction and human
costs specifically deploying and
babysitting infrastructure data
processing analysis is about writing
amazing pipelines and queries to solve
business problems not deploying and
managing servers now I only touched on
cloud pub/sub
cloud dataflow and bigquery really to
drill home the point about the power of
managed services
and streaming engine composability but
there is so much additional power on the
Google cloud platform for data
processing if you want to bring your
existing Hadoop workloads to the cloud
great we have amazing
Manit support for Hadoop via cloud data
proc if you want ultra low latency high
throughput durable storage for changing
key data cloud BigTable is an excellent
managed alternative to stand-alone HBase
if you want highly available globally
addressable no sequel datastore is an
excellent solution if you want managed
my sequel try out cloud sequel now
beyond being a platform leader for
streaming processing the Google cloud
platform is an amazing place for any
scale of data processing and analysis I
will leave you with the simplest of
advice if you've not already I encourage
you to go and read the docs for cloud
pub/sub dataflow and bigquery
understand the value and feature set of
each product then specifically go bet
out the cloud dataflow mobile gaming
example it's a solid implementation of
the feature set grounded in real-world
use cases then write your own pipeline
but keep it simple answer one question
endow it and then build from there
finally have fun thank you